foreign
let's go to Greenville South Carolina
and talk to D Money David what's up
David
oh not much John glad to be on the
number one Healthcare podcast
not Healthcare man I don't know much
about that that not Healthcare but
mental health there you go it's the hey
if you say it long enough it just
happens it's incredible so I'm just
going to keep repeating that despite
most of the evidence to the contrary
what's up man and since you don't horse
noises anymore
listen the amount of meetings we had
over the horse noises I'm still in
therapy over that but it's good thank
you for remembering where my heart used
to be before Kelly took it away
hey so what's up
so my question for you is how do I heal
from childhood trauma when I don't even
really remember things from my childhood
um
give me the context for this like
there's a reason why you're calling
what's what's popping up what about the
way you're responding to things in your
current life you don't like
so I have a bad temper
um don't like myself don't like my job
uh stress with the kids and the wife
um you know life just sucks
what about it sucks man
I mean just
everything my marital relationship sucks
my relationship with my kids sucks my
relationship with my parents Now sucks
uh I don't have a relationship with
either of my brothers growing up and you
know there was some major trauma that
that happened to my older brother and my
younger brother
um when we were all children and I you
know we had a family motto I swear it
was you know things are need to know and
you don't need to know because I wasn't
told anything about what happened to
either of them until adulthood okay
um you know my yeah what does that make
you mad right now
um like you the way you're describing
that is you're put out about it are they
supposed to pull you in a room as an
eight-year-old and be like hey just want
to let you know that your brother was
sexually assaulted like what were you
expecting so
my brother went to jail over
what happened to him and then what he
did
you know five or six years later no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
no
he went to jail because of what he did
right right
um
and
like there was no you know he's just
gone and there's no
you know explanation of
why he's not there other than your
brother was assaulted he assaulted
somebody else
you know
and that was pretty much it no do you
need to talk about this with somebody
you know the kid that he assaulted was
in the neighborhood you knew him you
weren't really friends with him but you
knew him yeah
um okay so so bring me to right now
that all the things you just mentioned
there's one common denominator
[Music]
what is it uh
well I guess me yeah
so what is it going on in you
that makes you
both believe and act like
you're not worth having a good marriage
you're not worth being a good employee
or you're not worth a a job it's worth a
crap
you're not worth having a good
relationship with your brothers or your
kids
what is it about you
that radiates that out everywhere
yeah I I really don't know you do I mean
why don't you like you
you know the answer to that question and
you've never said it out loud so say it
why don't you like you
you know I I don't know I honestly do
not know
I mean it's it's
I I thought about it I've read your book
and I'm I'm stumbling through it and I'm
just like you know I really don't know I
have this lack of self-awareness you
know but something but but something is
holding you back from going to get it
right
like I was a bundling idiot when I got
married and then my wife said these
things have to be different
and I thought hey I'm worth more than
this
B I value my marriage C I'm desperately
in love with this woman and I want this
to work and so that left me with two
options do nothing and blow it up or go
learn some new tools
so but something's holding you back and
it has for a long time what is it
okay
so here's where you find yourself I
don't know
and you're standing there and everything
around you is on fire is that fair
yeah okay
if you happen to be in a home
and you find that it's on fire and you
run to the next room and it's on fire
and you run into the kitchen and it's on
fire
sitting there and trying to figure out
who did this and what happened and
where's the Short
is a dangerous game right
the best thing to do is to get out of
that house and try to figure out how to
put the fire out
it might be that you can do it yourself
with hoses it might be that you need to
call some professionals in to help you
and then When the Smoke Clears then you
go through and you pick up the pieces
and then you figure out what comes next
okay so all right
trying to figure out what happened when
you're a child right now maybe that's
not the best use of your time
I have a feeling that you don't need any
more time thinking that you've been
thinking and talking and really talking
crap to yourself for a long long long
time and getting mad at other people the
way that it was presented to you about
your brother gives me one little pinhole
of light into the way your home
functioned which is our problems are
because of everybody else
which may have turned you into a 47 year
old or 50 year old of you
47 47 year old uh
uh everything it must be something from
my childhood because I just my my family
man
go back to the that book you read and
just look at the title own it this is
where I am
and then you have to ask yourself that
terrifying scary question what am I
gonna do now
and that's not like uh let's overthink
this let's start changing our actions
right now
so give me a thing you could do right
now that would improve your
relationships
no I don't know how to show emotion too
hard too hard
stop yelling
stop yelling quit yelling at people who
love
I don't even think I'm yelling at like
you're saying you're angry and I'm like
I'm not angry I'm just trying to I'm not
saying I didn't say you're angry
at the beginning of the call you were
like I can hear the anger in your voice
and I'm like I don't have any anger in
my voice but maybe I do and just don't
feel it okay so what you know now is you
have a feeling that tells you one thing
and you've got empirical data that tells
you something else
and so cool
I'm gonna trust you
does your wife tell you hey
um I don't like the way you're talking
to me or I just wanna she does things
that are gonna go a little bit to the
right because she doesn't want to fight
you anymore
all the time okay let that be a cue and
say cool I've got something I got to
work on I'm clearly not seeing it
but I do trust her do you trust her
yeah okay
I
[Music]
if you listen to your body dude it will
let you know
when's the last time you got worked up
and you got angry about something
um
trying to think of one I know has been
one in the last couple of days I'm sure
something led to this phone call what
was it
um
just where my wife and I are at
where are you and I mean we're
so close to divorce it's not funny why
because she says that she needs
emotional intimacy and I don't even
understand what she's talking about I
don't know how to give it to her I don't
know what it is have you gone kicking in
the doors of a local therapist saying I
need to learn this now because I'm about
to lose everything
Yeah Yeah we actually were in counseling
with a therapist and
yep
it was
I I don't know if he was just trying to
make more money he sucked okay cool I
got an appointment today with another
one there you go man now now you're
talking
and if you lead that with I need to
learn emotional intimacy
most guys I talk to who are struggling
with emotional intimacy
um
have been told since they were very very
young that doesn't hurt suck it up get
up yeah
right you know they've been told since
they were zero that you don't really
know how your body feels I do it didn't
hurt get going
nobody wants to hug you if you hug
somebody it's because you're this or
you're that or you're some kind of
little pains get up right and so men are
socialized to divorce themselves from
emotions
and then they get married and their
partner says that's all I care about
from you
and then we're standing there going uh I
don't know what to do right so dude this
is just a set of skills man
it's a set of skills and if you went to
um a mechanic and the mechanic did a
terrible job you wouldn't have an
existential crisis about it you would
just take your car somewhere else
and you would let your friends know I'm
not gonna use that mechanic anymore let
this be the same thing with your
therapist
is that fair
yeah
you gotta learn some skills man
there's there's something beneath the
emotional intimacy though what is it
okay
[Applause]
I really don't know I re I mean I just
you know
why are you about to divorce her
I'm not
I mean I
I heard her in the past I was an [ __ ]
many years ago I know that okay
um and
you know we we got into an argument the
other day and she brought something up
that you know to me it's 12 years old
it's
you know long time ago and I'm past it
and she's like I just want an apology
and I'm like now if I give you one it's
not heartfelt
why
why would why would that be your
response David what are you protecting
listen you have such a core ego that is
so thin that you are protect you you've
layered shame and you've layered tough
guy and you've layered uh like a very
immature exterior core ready to bite
anybody that comes after that little kid
inside why
were you sexually abused as a kid
I don't think so okay then let it ride
did your parents beat you up as a kid or
neglect you or leave you on the outside
okay
that sucks and they shouldn't have done
that
and your wife doesn't deserve that exact
same treatment that was done to you does
she
and your kids don't either do they
no
they learn a few new skills man and
practice the hell out of them
when your body hurts or you find
yourself getting angry or you start to
say something like well I'm not going to
apologize because it won't even be real
why stop
how is that ever a good answer to the
woman that you love
outside of taking a knee and say or
instead of taking a knee and saying
honey for 12 years I didn't know you
were carrying this around I'm sorry
foreign you mean that
I just I'm tired of the past
in my future I'm just ready to move past
it that's fair that is absolutely Fair
in the moment you own it and take
responsibility for what you can
you can be through with it
forgetting about it and ignoring it
doesn't work
carrying around those bricks of anger
about your parents they didn't tell you
something when you were 14. okay here's
the deal they screwed up they should
have sat you down and said your brother
did something terrible and he heard a
kid in the neighborhood and now he's
going to jail they should have done that
and they didn't
and now there's a period at the end of
that sentence
and the more you revisit that sentence
and say they should have done this and I
wish that hey man all you're doing is
gearing your body up for a war that it
can't fight
and so you become the only casualty over
and over again
your parents screwed up man period now
what
see what I'm saying yeah and I'm telling
you this because I love you man and I'm
tired of I it breaks my heart that you
carry this around with you
your brother did something evil
and I'm sorry and something was done to
your other brother man that ripples
through families in a way that few
people could understand and I'm sorry
and now what
[Applause]
what keeps you from
exercising five times a week what keeps
you from going to sleep what keeps you
from asking your wife hey what does
today look like how can I best love you
today
what keeps you from taking each one of
your kids out by themselves and saying
so
the first half of our time together I
haven't done so great but I'm learning
and I'm going to start by saying I'm
sorry and I'm going to start by saying I
love you
can I hold you for a minute
yeah I've done that okay
so
no dude is that
it's not I did that so it's not a
checklist man it's a way of being
oh
do you not want to are you out
no I don't want to be out I just I feel
like I just can't do it you ah you can
you can
you want to win the championship and you
don't want to go to the weight room
no I don't want to go to the weight room
I will I will not
deny that but you eat no you want to win
you want to be standing up there holding
that big trophy but you don't want to go
on the team Retreat and you don't want
to eat right
and you don't want to fill in the blank
and
as a guy who's dealt with my fair share
of trauma I'm telling this from one guy
to another so imagine you and I just
sitting at a table having a beer and I'm
looking at you and I want you to hear me
say this that's immature man it's time
yeah it's time
and yes I can tell you that your wife is
worth it your kids are worth it and all
that stuff but you David and I hate the
fact that no one's ever told you that
but they haven't and here we are
so what comes next
give me a David identity
I mean honestly David feels like a loser
idiot no no no no who's David gonna be
who's David gonna become
I don't know if David can do it
he can
I've seen it too many times
and I've held too many people's hands in
the black hole
covered Nash you can
will you
I'm gonna try
what does that mean
s I'm gonna
tell my wife how sorry I am
tell my kids
again will you tell David
you leave David out of this man
you love your wife and your kids way
more than David and I'm I
you've got to be able to look in the
mirror and see value
I don't okay
that's fair
but just talking to you for 15 minutes
I'm telling you you got value
whether you see it or not
and I think if there's one theme of this
call it's that
um for any number of reasons probably
multiple reasons
your body's feelings your body's alarm
systems that go off when it feels unsafe
or threatened
our attitude
the either the batteries have worn down
on some of them or they are Super Hyper
sensitive and they are there to protect
you from fights that you're not even
having
and it's important that you get people
around you that can help be your compass
for a while while those things retune
and all that all
it's a it's a chore to relearn that
stuff make no mistake
but it's not a chore
to just start each day with asking
how can I love you today
and I don't care what you feel like when
she says
man it'd really help if you help with
the dishes and you help with this and
got kids off to school and it would
really it would mean a lot to me if you
would run to the gym for 15 minutes and
just work off some of that
mean a lot to me if you'd apply for a
new job because I hate what this job's
doing to you
and your first thought is I don't feel
like any of that it's not even going to
be true to me bro just do it anyway man
okay okay
but in
I loved
you've heard me talk about the Twin
Towers right
yep I would love for you to take your
wife out somewhere for lunch or dinner
tonight and tell her that same thing
that you want to build something new and
you're willing to do what it takes
yeah I don't think she'll believe me
we've actually talked about it that's
fun
does she have reason to believe you at
this point
no okay
you can tell her that
and then it's going to take a deck of
note cards my brother
go get a deck of note cards for 95 cents
at Walgreens or Walmart or something and
just write out here's what I'm gonna do
tomorrow
and then here's I'm gonna do the next
day after that
I wish it was more complicated than that
man and it's not and yes it's going to
be really important for you go talk to a
counselor because you got some stuff to
unwind and some skills to learn which is
great
but in the meantime
let's just commit to acting let's do it
for 30 days man can you do it for 30
days
yeah
will you make me that promise
I'll make you that promise okay
will you holler back at me in 30 days
after this
I can do that okay
I'm gonna call it a deal you're gonna
haul back at me in 30 minutes I mean 30
days after this and we're gonna see how
it is okay and if your wife wants to
call I'd love to talk to her too
here's my deal
you
Are The Brave name and face of Millions
millions of men in in the United States
who are done they're exhausted they're
tired they're just done
and as a guy with a 12 year old little
boy and a six-year-old little girl
I can't have you cash out man I need you
we need you
you need you
so I'll walk alongside you
if you keep being brave and keep taking
the next step
and you go get yourself a cheap pack of
note cards and say today I'm going to
start doing stuff different
I'm gonna fake it till I make it I'm
gonna act different I'm gonna do what I
gotta do
to learn this new set of skills so I
don't lose my wife and I don't lose my
kids and I don't repeat the cycle at
some point we stop and say I'm gonna
Stare this sucker down
that's courage my brother I'm proud of
you David
30-day challenge here we go